[Aplausos]
[Música]
hoy vamos a hablar de la república
popular democrática de corea el único
país cuyo nombre en sí mismo es ya una
ironía
hablamos de una nación que lleva más de
70 años gobernada por la misma familia
en el gobierno de pyongyang el cargo de
jefe de estado es hereditario y ojo que
no se llama ni presidente ni rey
oficialmente el título que ostenta kim
jong-un es el del líder supremo en fin
que podemos decir de corea del norte que
no hayáis oído millones de veces
se trata de la dictadura más salvaje del
planeta donde las torturas las
ejecuciones y la extrema pobreza son más
que habituales pero ahora os
preguntaréis por qué nos preocupa tanto
este país pues bien la respuesta es tan
sencilla como que tienen bombas atómicas
hablamos de un país que oficialmente
sigue en guerra con corea del sur que
continuamente está lanzando amenazas
contra japón o eeuu y que cada equis
tiempo realiza pruebas de su arsenal
nuclear en sus costas en otras palabras
que hay razones de sobra para tomarse al
querido líder en serio
y os preguntaréis por qué nadie se
atreve a pararle los pies a corea del
norte pues bien una de las razones por
las cuales la comunidad internacional
continúa respetando a esta dictadura es
su amistad con china
[Música]
china y korea están tan próximos como
los labios a los dientes sin embargo las
cosas ya no son lo que eran chinas se
está cansando de tener continuamente que
dar la cara por su hermano tonto así que
la pregunta ahora es por qué china y
korea del norte están enfriando sus
relaciones
[Música]
y lo que es más importante qué
consecuencias puede tener esto para el
futuro del país hoy vamos a responder a
estas preguntas y lo vamos a hacer de la
mano de uno de los mayores expertos de
china que hay en todo youtube y amigos
de visual política estoy hablando nada
más y nada menos que de crisis chapel el
presentador de china and sensor hola
fonseca y un abrazo a todos los amigos
del world awards
éste cuestionase the world work with it
y bomberiles inactivas
i
com
ander line en otras palabras que china y
corea del norte está muy cerquita del
divorcio pero porque que ha pasado para
que estos dos países hayan dejado de
llevarse bien ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
'china frame zone a a corea del norte
tras la segunda guerra mundial japón
retira sus tropas tanto de china como de
corea ambos países se dividen en dos
facciones una comunista y una anti
comunista ambos países comparten
fronteras y ambos países tanto corea del
norte como la china continental
terminaron estando dirigidos por un
líder carismático que defendía el
marxismo en su versión más radical
[Música]
vamos podéis imaginar estas dos naciones
estaban llamadas para entenderse y eso
explica que durante los últimos 70 años
china y corea del norte han sido algo
así como el puente inter anti no y
robert rodríguez de la política
internacional robert rodríguez y yo
estamos con los culos justo desde que
nos conocimos somos hermanos de objeto
porque todo lo que digo
le gusta el a robert rodríguez
way
[Música]
3 de innings
sainz y os preguntaréis que recibe pekín
a cambio pues bien por un lado tienen a
un aliado con arsenal nuclear una cosa
que podría ser muy útil si algún día las
cosas se pusieran realmente mal pero no
sólo eso
corea del norte es también un paraíso de
mano de obra barata y muchos de esos
productos que ponen en la etiqueta made
in china en realidad debería decir made
in north korea
la firma de ropa deportiva récord ha
pedido disculpas públicamente después de
descubrir que uno de sus trajes de esquí
han sido hechos en una de las fábricas
estatales de corea del norte pero
esperad un momento porque las cosas
están empezando a cambiar en las últimas
décadas china no solo se está abriendo
económicamente sino que además quiere
cultivar buenas relaciones diplomáticas
con el resto del mundo así que imaginad
lo difícil que es intentar llevarse bien
con eeuu cuando a la vez tienes que
justificar que tu aliado quiere
bombardear los un poquito complicado
verdad pero la cosa va mucho más allá
hace 60 años china y corea del norte
eran dos países muy parecidos pero hoy
en día no tienen absolutamente nada que
ver
chávez gentes y estos turistas han
venido a ver de cerca la experiencia
miserable de sus vecinos norcoreanos no
soy mayor pero creo que lo que estoy
viendo ahí es muy parecido a cómo estaba
nuestro país en el pasado muchos de
estos norcoreanos matarían por cruzar la
frontera con china y pekín tiene miedo
de lo que podría ser una crisis de
refugiados similar a la que está
ocurriendo con los sirios
dyn
un grupo de pop femenino creado por kim
jong-un ha cancelado de manera abrupta
un concierto en pekín y se ha vuelto a
pyongyang
[Música]
pero sin duda alguna febrero del año
2017 ha sido el momento clave para
romper esta bonita amistad
united states
word word countries meeting podcast
twist hersaling the elder pero la cosa
no se queda en meras palabras recordáis
que china había formado a aquellos
hackers norcoreanos que años más tarde
piratearon las cuentas y los servidores
de algunas productoras de hollywood pues
ya sabes lo que dice el refrán cría
cuervos y te sacarán los ojos
[Música]
esta ola de llamados ataques ransomware
han golpeado duramente a china si corea
del norte fuera responsable aunque no
fuera a propósito sería el primer
intento conocido por parte de pyongyang
de robar en las arcas de china a
semejante escala en otras palabras que
si no cambian mucho las cosas corea del
norte podría perder a su único aliado el
único país dispuesto a defenderles en
caso de una potencial guerra y hablamos
de una guerra que aunque sólo sea por
motivos propagandísticos muchos tendrían
ganas de librar
putin y trump entran en escena ya sé lo
que estáis pensando
fonseca menuda historia más turbia nos
estás contando solo falta que aparezca a
vladimir putin para que esto sea un
vídeo de visual político como dios manda
pues bien aquí lo tenéis
[Música]
rusia ya controla el suministro de
combustible para aviones para corea del
norte después de que china hubiera
interrumpido sus exportaciones
washington
m
[Música]
[Aplausos]
en el vodka andrés y minorista interior
opinó roger en nuestra historia pero
services de que next day and drinks su
relación companies que en vivo del
estado othón no es creyente soleil word
force desde mi inclusión en qué manera
bastings pues no del todo porque resulta
que nuestro amigo kim jong-un tiene un
sentido un poquito raro de lo que es la
amistad
de corea del norte cae en el mar cerca
de rusia
[Música]
a ver kim jong-un hijo mío tú crees que
estas son formas pues no no lo son como
os podéis imaginar con detalles como
este a rusia se le quitan las ganas de
defender a corea del norte a capa y
espada así que tenemos que por primera
vez el estado más odiado del mundo se ha
quedado sin aliados y aquí es cuando por
fin entra donald trump cuidado picture
tenemos un gran problema alguien no está
haciendo lo correcto y esto va a ser una
irresponsabilidad hay todo esto mientras
china intenta llegar a un acuerdo de
libre comercio con eeuu
a la vez donald trump no gana para
escándalos en su propia casa incluso
algunos diputados republicanos se están
planteando presentar una moción de
censura por el escándalo de las
filtraciones a rusia
[Música]
así que la pregunta que queda en el aire
es podría donald trump invadir corea del
norte para apuntarse un tanto y ganar
puntos de cara a sus votantes podría ser
este el fin de la dictadura norcoreana
podeis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios
mientras tanto si queréis saber más
sobre esta ruptura de relaciones entre
china y corea del norte o simplemente
queréis profundizar un poco más en la
cultura y política china no dejéis de
visitar tainán and sensor es un canal de
youtube centrado al cien por cien en
este país mismo
ser
y por supuesto no olvidéis que sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribiros al canal para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones si
os ha gustado este vídeo dadle a like y
nos vemos en el próximo un abrazo y
hasta pronto
[Música]
y